THE CONCEPT OF A PRESIDENTIAL
LIBRARY, A SHRINE TO A FORMER
PRESIDENT IS A RELATIVELY
NEW IDEA.
FOR THE FIRST HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS OF THIS COUNTRY'S
EXISTENCE, PRESIDENTS DIDN'T
HAVE LAVISH MONUMENTS BUILT
TO COMMEMORATE THE ROLE.
THE WHOLE NOTION WOULD HAVE
REPULSED THE MEN WHO WAGED WAR
WITH A MONARCHY TO BUILD THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT STARTING WITH THE FDR, OF
COURSE, PRESIDENT , LIBRARIES
BECAME CUSTOMARY AND THEY'VE
GRADUALLY TRANSFORMED FROM THAT
,FROM LIBRARIES INTO
MULTI-MILLION DOLLAR TEMPLE
TO HUBRIS, THE MOST RECENT EX
PRESIDENT TO GET HIS VERY
TEMPLE.
AND THE BIGGEST OF ALL, OF
COURSE, IS BARACK OBAMA.
THE TOTAL COST OF HIS LIBRARY
CLOCKS IN AT ABOUT HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS.
DESTRUCTION BEGAN LAST YEAR
WHEN OBAMA DEMANDED THAT HIS
DONORS PAY FOR IT.
>> BUT TODAY, CONSTRUCTION OF
THE TEMPLE WAS HALTED BECAUSE
OF AN EMERGENCY.
>> NO, NOT A FIRE.
NOT A LIGHTNING STRIKE.
ACCORDING TO A CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY WORKING ON THE LIBRARY,
QUOTE THIS MORNING, WE WERE
INFORMED THAT AN ACTIVE HATE
WAS DISCOVERED AT THE PROJECT'S
SITE.
AND YOU KNEW THE ACTIVE HATE
WAS SERIOUS.
BECAUSE THE MEDIA WENT ALL IN.
THEY DEVOTE A LOT OF TIME
TO TALKING ABOUT THIS
ON THE BRINK OF NUCLEAR WAR
AND RECESSION.
BUT THE ACTIVE HATE
ON THE OBAMA CONSTRUCTION SITE
LED THE NEWS WATCH CONSTRUCTION
AT THE OBAMA PRESIDENTIAL
CENTER IN CHICAGO IS SUSPENDED
AFTER A NOOSE WAS DISCOVERED AT
THE SITE ON THURSDAY.
AN ACT OF HATE, A NOOSE
IS FOUND AT THE SITE OF
THE OBAMA PRESIDENTIAL CENTER.
>> A NOOSE WAS FOUND AT
THE SITE.
ILLINOIS GOVERNOR JB PRITZKER,
CONDEMNING THE HATEFUL ACT
AND UGLY RACIST SYMBOL WAS
FOUND AT THE FUTURE SITE OF
THE OBAMA PRESIDENTIAL CENTER.
A NOOSE WAS DISCOVERED AT
THE CONSTRUCTION SITE THIS
MORNING.
OPERATIONS WERE HALTED AND THE
POLICE WERE CALLED.
A ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
REWARD HAS BEEN OFFERED FOR
INFORMATION LEADING TO THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT OFFICIALS
DESCRIBED AS THIS SHAMELESS ACT
OF COWARDICE AND HATE.
>> A LOT OF HUFFING
AND PUFFING.
HAVE YOU HEARD A STORY LIKE
THIS BEFORE?
WELL, IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO
IN THE MIDDLE OF A NATIONAL
CRIME WAVE, WHICH IT HAS DONE
VERY LITTLE TO SOLVE.
THE FBI RUSHED A TEAM OF AGENTS
TO A NASCAR GARAGE AFTER
A CHARACTER CALLED BUBBA
WALLACE SUGGESTED THAT A NOOSE
HAD BEEN LEFT IN THAT GARAGE.
TURNS OUT THE NEWS WAS A GARAGE
DOOR PULL.
>> OH, HERE'S THE INTERESTING
THING.
EVERYONE MAKES MISTAKES, BUT
MISTAKES LIKE THIS NEVER
GET CORRECTED.
NOBODY EVER APOLOGIZED FOR
THAT.
NOT THE MEDIA, NOT THE FBI.
AND CERTAINLY NOT BUBBA
WALLACE.
IN FACT, BUBBA WALLACE SAID
THAT ONLY STUPID PEOPLE WOULD
DOUBT HIS STORY EVEN AFTER WAS
PROVEN TO BE FALSE.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOUBTING THAT
THIS EVEN HAPPENED OR THAT IT'S
TRUE?
>> YEAH, JUST LIKE STEVE SAID,
IT OFFENDS ME THAT PEOPLE WOULD
GO TO THOSE MEASURES.
BUT AGAIN, I'M NOT SHOCKED.
IT'S SIMPLE MINDED PEOPLE LIKE
THAT, THE ONES THAT ARE AFRAID
OF CHANGE, THEY THEY USE
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER
TO DEFEND WHAT THEY STAND UP
FOR.
AND INSTEAD OF TRYING TO LISTEN
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU
ALLEGED , IQRAA CRIME,
HARDISTY, THAT'S A CRIME.
BUT WHATEVER WORTHY
THE ATTENTION OF THE FBI, THIS
IS ALL INSANE.
>> BUT YOU WERE WRONG.
BUT INSTEAD OF APOLOGIZING,
YOU'RE LECTURING PEOPLE LIKE
THEY'RE YOUR MORAL INFERIORS
FOR ASKING QUESTIONS.
AND IT WAS OBVIOUS FROM
THE BEGINNING OF WALLACE'S
STORY MADE NO SENSE SAYING
HE'S MAKING IT UP, BUT HE WAS
WRONG.
AND THERE IS A HIGH LIKELIHOOD
THAT THIS NOOSE, IF BARACK
OBAMA'S TEMPLE MIGHT BE A HOAX
TO A LOT OF THESE STORIES, ARE
WHY DO THEY KEEP APPEARING?
WE'LL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE ACCUSATIONS OF HATE
CRIMES AND BIAS MORE GENERALLY
ARE TOOLS THAT THE PEOPLE IN
POWER USED.
NOT THE POWER WAS THE POWERFUL
TOWARD THEMSELVES, GREATER
AND TOTALLY UNEARNED MORAL
AUTHORITY OVER EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> AND BARACK OBAMA IS THE
PERFECT EXAMPLE.
OPPRESSED, REALLY.
OBAMA IS A HALF WHITE GUY
WITH AN IVY LEAGUE DEGREE
WHO SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES FOR TWO TERMS
AND LIVES IN TWO OCEANFRONT
COMPOUNDS IN THE RICH ZIP CODES
IN THE WORLD.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE
OPPRESSION?
NO, IT SOUNDS PRIVILEGE.
>> THAT'S FINE.
BUT NO, THEY TELL YOU
HE'S EMMETT TILL.
HE'S POWLES VICTIM OF
YOUR RACISM.
SO WHEN YOU MAKE ALLEGATIONS
LIKE THAT, NOBODY GETS TO ASK
THE OBVIOUS QUESTIONS LIKE
WHERE DID YOU GET ALL THIS
MONEY?
HOW ARE YOU MAKING A LIVING?
HOW'D YOU GET SO RICH?
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN SELLING IN
EXCHANGE FOR THAT MONEY?
AND BY THE WAY, WHY ARE YOU
SPENDING A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS ON A PRESIDENTIAL
LIBRARY?
>> YOU'LL GET TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS, BECAUSE ALL YOU KNOW
IS THAT SOMEBODY LEFT A NEWS AT
A CONSTRUCTION SITE BECAUSE
THIS IS AN IMMORAL, RACIST
COUNTRY.
ALL THE PEOPLE BELOW ME ARE BAD
PEOPLE.
>> PEOPLE ON TOP ARE GOOD
THE BAD PEOPLE IN THE BOTTOM
ARE CREATING A COUNTRY FULL OF
RACISM THAT'S SO PERVASIVE
AND SCARY THAT WE HAVE TO PAUSE
CONSTRUCTION ON THE TEMPLE JUST
TO CATCH OUR BREATH.
OBAMA TOLD US MANY TIMES
BEFORE, THIS IS A BAD COUNTRY.
HE TOLD US FOR EIGHT YEARS HE
KNEW FROM HIS OWN LIFE THAT
PROGRESS IS FRAGILE, THAT WE
HAVE TO BE VIGILANT AGAINST
THE DARKER CURRENTS OF THIS
COUNTRY'S HISTORY, OF OUR OWN
HISTORY, WITH WITH WHIRLPOOLS
OF VIOLENCE AND HATRED
AND DESPAIR THAT CAN ALWAYS
RISE AGAIN.
>> BULL CONNOR MAY BE GONE, BUT
TODAY WE WITNESS WITH OUR OWN
EYES POLICE OFFICERS KNEELING
ON THE NECKS OF BLACK
AMERICANS.
>> BULL CONNOR MIGHT BE GONE,
BUT YOU STILL EXIST AND YOU'RE
OPPRESSING EVERYBODY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO OPPRESS YOU.
THIS LATEST OFFENSE AGAINST
ONE OF THE WORLD'S MOST
POWERFUL MEN IS SO APPALLING.
THAT THE AUTHORITIES HAVE
OFFERED ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR REWARD TO ANYONE WHO CAN
FIND THE PERSON WHO LEFT
A NOOSE AT OBAMA'S PRESIDENTIAL
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE VICTIMIZE BARACK
OBAMA YET AGAIN AND HIS WIFE.
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING IS FOR
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT THERE'S NO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR REWARD
OUTSTANDING FOR THE , SAY,
THOUSANDS OF UNSOLVED MURDERS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND THAT'S A LOT OF MURDERS.
IN FACT, ROUGHLY HALF
THE MURDERS THAT OCCUR IN
THE UNITED STATES ARE NOW NEVER
SOLVED BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
BECOMING THIRD WORLD OR
ANYTHING.
THOMAS HARGROVE, WHO RUNS
THE MURDER ACCOUNTABILITY
PROJECT , PUT IT THIS WAY VERY
CRISPLY.
>> IT'S A 50 50 COIN FLIP.
IT'S NEVER BEEN THIS BAD DURING
THE LAST SEVEN MONTHS OF
TWENTY .
TWENTY MOST MURDERS WENT
UNSOLVED.
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
IN AMERICA.
NOW, WHY IS THAT HAPPENING?
BECAUSE NOBODY CARES.
THAT'S WHY.
AND WHERE THESE MURDERS
HAPPENING?
OH, IN OBAMA'S HOMETOWN OF
CHICAGO, A LOT OF THEM WATCH
THAT MASS SHOOTING WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT IN CHICAGO.
>> IN THE TROUBLED WEST SIDE OF
TOWN WHERE THE BLOODSHED
IS FREQUENT.
IT HAPPENED ABOUT NINE THIRTY
P.M. LOCAL TIME.
PEOPLE HAD GATHERED FOR A VIGIL
.
POLICE SAY IT WAS AN SUV THAT
PULLED UP.
TWO GUNMEN OPENED FIRE AND
SPRAYED BULLETS INTO THE CROWD.
THE WHOLE THING WAS OVER IN
ABOUT THREE SECONDS.
FOURTEEN PEOPLE WERE INJURED.
WITNESSES SAY ONE MAN WAS SHOT
IN THE HEAD AND ONE PERSON WAS
HIT BY A CAR IN THE CHAOS.
BUT AMONG THE VICTIMS ARE
A THREE YEAR OLD AND 11 YEAR
OLD AND A 13 YEAR OLD BOY.
THE REST OF THE VICTIMS ARE
SAID TO BE DALT.
OKAY, DOES ANYONE CARE?
NO.
NOBODY IN POWER CARES.
NOT AT ALL ABOUT ANY OF THESE
CRIMES.
ACTUAL CRIMES.
IN NEVADA, AN ILLEGAL
ALIEN CALLED CARLOS NAVA, WHO'S
BEEN DEPORTED SEVEN TIMES BUT
IS STILL HERE BECAUSE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS HIS
VOTE , IS NOW FACING CHARGES
THAT HE FIVE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY OVER NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE WERE.
>> DID ANYONE EVER FOR
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR HIS ARREST OR TO GIVE HIS
VICTIMS?
BUT WE'VE GOT
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO SPARE FOR WHOEVER TIED THAT
PIECE.
OF STRING IN A FORBIDDEN SHAPE
OF BARACK OBAMA'S CONSTRUCTION
SITE.
>> REALLY?
>> AGAIN, IF ALL THE MORAL
OUTRAGE WERE DIRECTED ON BEHALF
OF PEOPLE WITH NO POWER
WHO ACTUALLY SUFFERING
AND THERE ARE MILLIONS OF
THE AMERICA YOU CAN KIND OF PUT
UP WITH IT.
BUT ALL THIS HUFFING
AND PUFFING OVER BARACK
MICHELLE OBAMA, MOST PEOPLE
DON'T SEE THEM AS A COLOR.
THEY SEE THEM FOR WHAT THEY ARE
,WHICH IS THE MOST PRIVILEGED
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
AND YET MICHELLE OBAMA SORT OF
WHOLE BOOK ABOUT HER STRUGGLE
TO , QUOTE, STAY VISIBLE IN
A WORLD DOESN'T NECESSARILY SEE
A TALL BLACK WOMAN.
>> WHAT YOU DON'T SEE MICHELLE
OBAMA.
>> SHE'S THE PRESIDENT'S WIFE
FOR EIGHT YEARS.
HOW MUCH MONEY IS MICHELLE
OBAMA MADE IN THE LAST
SIX YEARS?
OH, YOU'D LOVE TO KNOW, BUT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO JUST ACCEPT
UNCRITICALLY, JUST LIKE YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THE JUSSIE
SMOLLETT HOAX.
WE'VE GOT SOME BREAKING NEWS.
ACTOR AND MUSICIAN JUSSIE
SMOLLETT FROM THE HIT SHOW
EMPIRE WAS ATTACKED AND BEATEN
EARLY THIS MORNING.
IN CHICAGO.
AND POLICE SAY IT COULD BE A
HATE CRIME.
THERE ARE MANY INDICATIONS OF
A HATE CRIME HERE.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR TWO
SUSPECTS WHO WERE APPARENTLY
WEARING MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN HATS.
>> WE HAVE A MEDIA THAT'S
SAYING IT'S A DEBATE WHETHER OR
NOT WHAT JUST HAPPENED TO JESSE
SMOLLETT IS A HATE CRIME, IT'S
ABSURD.
JUSSIE SMOLLETT HAD UNUSUAL
ON HIS NECK JUST THIS WEEK.
AND THE MEDIA HAS REALLY CAST
SO MUCH DOUBT ON HIS STORY,
WHICH I FIND SO PERSONAL
OFFENSIVE THAT A  BLACK MAN
IS TARGETED AND THEN SUDDENLY
HE BECOMES THE VICTIM OF
PEOPLE'S DISBELIEF.
HE SAID HIS ATTACKERS HURLED
RACIAL AND HOMOPHOBIC SLURS AT
HIM.
THIS IS AMERICA IN 2019.
>> THIS IS AMERICA IN 2019,
WHERE THE MOST POWERFUL PEOPLE
OR THE MOST FREQUENTLY
VICTIMIZED.
AND THAT REALLY IS THE MESSAGE
IS THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE, PEOPLE
WITH POWER OVER YOUR LIFE,
THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE THE LAWS,
PEOPLE WHO SHAPE YOUR CULTURE
AND SOME PEOPLE CAN PUT YOU IN
JAIL.
CERTAINLY PEOPLE ARE PAID A LOT
MORE THAN YOU ARE.
THEY'RE THE REAL VICTIMS.
NO, THEY'RE THE REAL VICTIMS.
SO WHAT ARE WE WATCHING?
WE'RE WATCHING A POWER PLAY.
OF COURSE, WE'RE WATCHING
A TRANSFER OF MORAL AUTHORITY
FROM THE POPULATION, A NATION
OF CITIZENS TO THE TOP ONE
PERCENT.
AND AS THE RECESSION DEEPENS
AND PEOPLE GET POORER, YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE A LOT MORE OF
THIS.
DON'T NOTICE MY LOOTING.
I'M THE VICTIM.
THAT'S WHY HILLARY CLINTON
PLAYS THE SEXISM CARD.
>> DON'T ASK QUESTIONS.
I'M A WOMAN HERE.
SHE IS .
SO ANY OF YOU WHO'VE READ MY
MY BOOK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
KNOW THAT I THINK THAT MISOGYNY
AND SEXISM IS PART OF THAT
CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS ONE OF THE CONTRIBUTING
FACTORS AND SOME OF IT WAS OLD
FASHIONED SEXISM AND A REFUSAL
TO ACCEPT THE EQUALITY OF WOMEN
AND CERTAINLY THE EQUALITY OF
WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP.
>> YEAH, THEY'LL DO IT.
CHELSEA CLINTON DOES IT.
NANCY PELOSI DOES IT.
A COSIO.
CORTEZ DOES IT.
KAMALA HARRIS DOES IT.
THE MOST POWERFUL PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD ARE ALWAYS TELLING
YOU THEY'RE VICTIMS.
JOE BIDEN CAN'T DO IT, OF
COURSE, BECAUSE HE'S A WHITE
MAN.
SO INSTEAD, HE ACCUSES YOU OF